ladies and gentlemen i give you the
first story from timcast.com
tim cast ceo puts billboard in times
square calling out washington post
reporters doxxing of libs of tick tock
taylor lorenz blocked timpool on twitter
after videos of the sign were posted
online oh i want to talk about this so
bad now we do have a disclaimer at the
top it says tim poole is the owner and
ceo of timcast media including
timcast.com because we have standards
this seems a little biased i'm going to
be honest
actually it's
not it's a straightforward news story i
don't know i gotta look into it i'm not
gonna take your word for it i have you i
have tim cast ceo of tim cass telling me
his article on tim cast about him the
ceo of tim cast isn't biased are you
expecting to buy that right now it is
not biased all right you see the fact
that we reveal that information shows
it's actually particularly
straightforward it's just several quotes
so a new message has joined the glowing
advertisements in new york city's times
square admonishing the washington post
for publishing private information of
the creator of libs of tiktok twitter
account
it shows statements from me
it shows that you know very
straightforward jeremy boring and and
tim cass put this together
taylor lorenz the technology reporter
for the washington post it shows uh i
believe uh just statements from me
mostly about it now i suppose you can
argue that taylor her responses should
have been included in the story but
considering it's just about the
billboard and why i did it i think
that's fair and i think it's fair when i
say you know this is how we're
addressing it what is it incredibly cool
and handsome ceo of tim cast
publishes awesome billboards
it also says super strong yeah yeah he's
really strong yeah and i won't take that
from you and his mom says he's the most
handsome yeah that's fair i think the
way this should have been framed is
bigoted far-right figure harass as a
poor innocent journalist
so let's let's let me tell you guys real
quick just about what happened
so we talked about putting up the
billboard we were like fingers crossed
they'll approve it they did all right i
think i will play for you the video
right here it's actually quite simple
it says democracy dies in darkness
turn that down
that's why we're shining a light on you
taylor loren's doxed at libs of tick
tock
at tim cast so first let me just address
uh some of the immediate points people
brought up why didn't we link to
anything why didn't we use it as an
opportunity to promote the [ __ ] you
can't yeah you can't you cannot use
other people's likenesses to advertise
your product
so there are rules restrictions and laws
also
i'm like i have to sign it i'm the one
who did it i'm not gonna pretend it
wasn't me
we're gonna put tim cast on it what else
are we gonna do i figured if we didn't
it would be i don't know i should i
should i should have my name on the
things that i'm doing so that's that's
ultimately how we decided to do it
the first thing that happens after we
put it up is taylor lorenz responded
saying
tim poole actually i think we might have
the the the tweets from taylor lorenz as
to what she what she said maybe not okay
hold on no i don't think we do but uh
taylor lorenz responded that tim paul
the ceo of the daily wire put up this
billboard
trying to discredit my journalism my
response was
that i i didn't uh want to discredit her
journalism actually i defended her
reporting on libs of tick tock however
she lied about doxing and that's what
needed to be called out her response was
or so so let me let me show you this
image i said to her
uh when her response was like you know a
goofy face saying oh the internet's so
crazy i said i'm glad you and your
friends are happy you made your point on
cnn i made mine in times square and now
we can move on she responded my family
and friends are not happy they have been
subject to a non-stop stream of hateful
attacks doxxing and violent attacks
driven by this baseless campaign happy
to hear you're moving on taylor i did
not insult you i did not dox you and i
defended your reporting i called you a
liar because you lied about doxing libs
of tick tock if you do not want to be
held to account for for a moral or
unethical activities you should not be
in media committing a moral or unethical
activities
i do not tolerate insulting the person
over over her appearance or age i do not
support doxing and i think libs of tick
tock should be reported on we need to
know who the influential people behind
our politics are but when you lie about
it you get called out now she's claiming
that there's violent attacks and it's
i'm part of this campaign oh you know
what just just spare me words are
violence remember that words are
violence that's where we're at
yep no i mean look it's no secret this
podcast has been swatted a number of
times people here have been threatened i
also have had people harass me do things
that have made me feel unsafe i have
been doxxed i don't like saying it i
don't like talking about it it's a
little bit weird to bring it up every
single time someone criticizes you
yeah it's funny because she's like this
is violence against me and then she
posts it
like i don't i don't think you're being
serious you know you know i think
when the story first comes out i tweeted
the link
she tweets it with a goofy face saying
oh these people are so crazy oh this
post is so dumb
but then when i said glad you're not
upset and we can move on she lost it she
blocked me immediately then started then
she made another tweet saying this is
the violence behind this and now she's
acting like it's the big attack against
her no i think she likes the press
what's the evidence of violence i'd like
to explain that to everybody well see
we've we've talked about this before
it's it's it's a fascinating thesis
see um if you grow up or or grow up in
in hardship
or uh perhaps you're in the armed forces
you experience real risks and real
threats
when you are at risk of losing your life
from the job you're working
you know what violence really is when
you've been punched attacked or
assaulted you know what violence really
is but if you are a soft-bellied i don't
know let's say your family's rich and
they sent you to like a swiss boarding
school and so you've never really
experienced hardship well no one's ever
dared speak ill of you so the first time
someone says a nasty word you get that
shock to your system like someone
attacked you they feel physical pain
like
you said what about me that's never
happened before she probably grew up
with participation awards and being told
she was great the whole time
yeah she went to a swiss boarding school
yeah
so uh i can't imagine someone like her
has actually experienced hardship but i
think i i don't think she's um i don't
think she's stupid
certainly she understands that she docks
libs of tiktok and is lying about it
because it's seriously easily proven
it's now been confirmed by multiple
sources
that's why i pulled up other sources we
have this from the washington free
beacon which is my friend's news guard
certified which says lorenz not only
revealed the identity of the anonymous
person who runs the account but also
included a copy of the person's real
estate license which showed her home
address the post later removed the home
address from the story then lied about
it saying we did not publish or link to
any details about our personal life
let me just show you taylor lorenz's
wikipedia which says
the article further publicized the
identity of the account owner as chair
reichik and provided personal details
okay
so she's lying it's obvious she's lying
and she knows she's lying tim what's her
motivation for doing that because
by exposing that poor those personal
details it's inviting
harassment minimally it's inviting
violence
you're calling her out and you're giving
them the directions to where to go get
her yeah i think
look i'm not going to give taylor the
benefit of the doubt i think they she or
whoever on the team included the link to
the private address knowing what they
were doing to terrorize
because
you know we've got security issues we
know exactly what it means and we have
we have armed guards now we have to get
armed security in a variety of fashions
so when someone publishes your address
in one of the most powerful and largest
institutional publications in the world
even if it's for only an hour or two
you know what that means it means you're
not safe and because of that the person
behind libs of tick tock had to flee to
a safe location
now
it's possible
that this is no longer the current
address of the individual all i know and
as we've reported
is that the address is listed in public
records as the private residence of the
individual
sometimes people have addresses listed
in the public and they move from them
and never change it i think it's a fair
point to make because i want to make
sure everyone's getting as much
understanding of what's going on as
possible
taylor lorenz has not provided any
evidence or any claim other than didn't
do it it's like okay well well here's
the link it's in the archive no didn't
do it
the washington post says they didn't
even link to it
well not you can actually just see the
link in the article in the archive yeah
and not only i didn't do it but you are
victimizing me by pointing out the fact
that i did it
correct
very slimy
i don't want to give them the benefit of
the doubt for putting that up but i
don't want to assume intent either so i
don't know exactly why it all happened
but here's the thing so ian even if they
didn't realize that this person was
going to be harassed and potentially
threatened and have their safety put at
risk when they publish their address
that would just make them incredibly
incompetent journalists who aren't
worthy of their platform so either way
it's horrible
hey i agree with that yeah massive
failure regardless
it has to be called out yeah i'm kind of
like
geez go easy on this but no don't
because they really made a journalistic
um faux pas or like like massive mistake
in in rendering you know as little harm
as possible to the people that you're
reporting on and that needs to be called
out so it doesn't happen again well
they always cry foul when it's done to
them
when they're called out when they're
named you know they're a victim right
away
and
they did it to somebody else and they're
denying it and they always deny and then
they move on and they don't want to be
held accountable what's that uh darvo is
that what it's called
i don't know i've heard of durvo or
something there's this thing they that
the left always says it's like deny
uh attack reverse victim
defender yes oh so you reverse the
victim and the offender you did that's
what she's doing you attack and then you
reverse the victim and the defender and
that's what taylor lorenz is doing
absolutely she's denying she did the
dachshund she's attacking people who who
are calling her out and she's making
herself the victim and the people who
she attacked the the you know the
offenders so it's funny because it's the
left that often tweets about that saying
the right does it but literally this is
what they do oh no i'm being it's like
that cartoon you ever see of the woman
the feminist and she's shoveling crap
over a wall and says opinions over the
internet and when they throw it back she
goes help i'm being oppressed it's like
welcome welcome to the real world listen
you do not get to wield institutional
power
as a weapon and then hide behind it
because now these people are starting to
realize what happens when other people
who also have the ability to wield
institutional power decide to strike
back and they're not going to like it
but i am done sitting around all we did
all we did is put up a simple message
taylor lorenz doc's lips of tik-tok i
did not insult her i did not post her
address i didn't reveal any private
information about her i made a simple
statement yeah that's it yeah well part
of what makes this so hideous is the
fact that a few weeks ago before this
was even a story taylor lorenz was on
msnbc and she started crying because she
said she fears for what people will do
with each tiny little bit of information
about her that was leaked so she's
clearly very conscious about this kind
of thing and then she went on to publish
somebody else's personal private address
and then lie about it and then lie about
it thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you